Speaker 1: Marjorie Taylor GREENE Yes, the
radical and repugnant Republican Congresswoman
Marjorie Taylor GREENE is reportedly being
considered to be Donald Trump's running mate
in 2024.
For months, reports Business Insider, Trump
has repeatedly discussed choosing Marjorie
Taylor GREENE as his 2024 running mate.
This is per Robert Draper of the New York
Times Magazine, as told to The Daily Beast.
Trump is considering Green.
This won't come as a surprise to you because
of her unflagging loyalty to him.
Speaking on this week's episode of The Daily
Beast's The New Abnormal podcast, Draper claimed
the discussions have been ongoing for months.
It's been discussed repeatedly.
Now, to be fair, I mean, how many of these
conversations has Trump had with other people?
What is Trump concerned about most of all
in a VP after the Mike Pence experience?
Loyalty.
Trump needs someone who will, quote, fight
for him to overturn a presidential election.
He has every reason to expect that GREENE
would be by his side and would be his proximate
warrior.
Earlier this week, Green told Draper she's
discussed with Trump the possibility of serving
as his running mate.
She said she would be honored to serve, but
the GOP establishment would not want it.
So listen, she's completely out of her mind.
Crazy.
She is.
Loyal is not even the right word.
But yes, she's unendingly loyal to Trump in
the sense of following whatever disastrous
instinct or talking point Trump is distracted
by that week as the latest shiny object.
I don't know.
On the one hand, why Trump thinks it would
help him to have Marjorie Taylor GREENE as
his running mate.
But in all seriousness, let's not write it
off.
And what I mean by that is remember that Trump
won the Republican primary of 2016.
Trump then won the presidential election.
You could come to me with tears in your eyes
and say, Sir, Trump is considering Jeffrey
Dahmer where he's still alive as VP.
And I'd say, That's insane, and he still might
win.
The most depressing era in a long time, for
sure.
And I don't think GREENE necessarily hurts
Trump.
Now, on the other hand, I don't know that
she necessarily helps.
And what I mean by that is, like, in all seriousness,
does Marjorie Taylor GREENE bring any new
voters to Donald Trump?
I don't know that she does.
If you are in the Romney wing of the Republican
Party or the Liz Cheney wing of the Republican
Party, and you don't like Democrats, but you're
just not sold on Trump.
If Trump picks Romney, maybe you go with the
Trump Romney ticket.
Now, that's not being considered.
I'm just saying maybe that gets you to go
over to the Trump side.
But if you're already in kind of like the
Romney, Kinzinger, Liz Cheney wing of the
Republican Party.
Does Trump picking Marjorie Taylor GREENE
get you over to Trump?
It doesn't seem like it.
And so on the one hand, I don't think because
of how delusional and dangerous and dystopian
this Republican Party and electorate is, I
don't know that there is anyone that would
really hurt Trump.
The thing about Marjorie Taylor GREENE is
I don't think she helps Trump find new voters,
which is what he needs to do if he hopes to
defeat Joe Biden or whoever it is on the Democratic
side in November of 24.
Because he needs to find some new voters relative
to 2020.
I don't know that Marjorie Taylor GREENE helps
him do that.
But I want to hear from you.
Let me know.